when you were backstage at our show the
guests that day
was Tom Cruise and I understood you were
you did your appearance you and Norman
but you guys hadn't met Tom Cruise
before so you hung around a little bit
yeah we stayed and watched a segment he
was there to promote Top Gun maverick
and we were super pumped and excited and
we we watched the the trailer which you
kind of showed some yeah came out and we
looked at each other it's like oh we
gotta meet him let's let's see if we can
meet him let's just stay so we we stayed
downstairs with all the I think his
people and some of our people and sure
enough he came down and we were just two
fanboys it was we were just completely
Top Gun family oh yeah would have been
like a teenager when that came I think I
was in I think I was in high school like
a young junior self more something like
that that movie was so cool that I think
there was a minute that I was like I'm
gonna be a pilot you know I am ready I
not the most accurate representation no
no probably not
we'll get to play volleyball on the
beach but I want to see her and remember
that people signing up for the military
like jump through yes yeah I was one of
the guys that thought about it but then
I was like well I'm just gonna take my
shirt off and play some volleyball and
get a motorcycle yeah unfortunately also
didn't look like Tom Cruise I didn't
quite have that you clean up okay yeah
well you what we have a that you took
your the nerve to get a picture with Tom
Cruise you in Norman I think we have it
right here and there we are that's nice
yes so we're bored cut out of Tom Cruise
by the way
that was what a beard on our show we
spend this time we talked to him for
like 20 minutes we were talking about
like motorcycles and God knows what else
because I don't really remember because
I kind of was really fanboy and hard and
at the end of it I was like look is it
cool if we get a photo with you because
we had decided no we're not gonna be
those guys and so I asked in Norman and
whispers my hair's like thank God
because now we got rid of that we got to
hang out with Tom Cruise he was too cool
to ask him I I wasn't afraid to make an
ass of myself so it was it was it was
most iPhones have a button an app that
you can just add Tom Cruise in day I
have pictures of him in everything we
should start that out if they don't
really have it that's a good you can
remove people you